[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález un secreto
revelado ha generado una nueva tormenta
política en perú al mejor estilo de los
huaycos para ponerlo en términos de ese
país los huecos son estas lluvias
torrenciales que causan inundaciones y
deslizamientos en pleno verano alguien
pero pues el llamado vacuna gates vuelve
a sacudir entonces a este país
suramericano cuando está a sólo semanas
de las elecciones presidenciales en qué
consiste una serie de funcionarios y
familiares y también personas cercanas a
ellos en total 487 para ser exactos se
vacunaron en secreto contra el joven 19
con dosis de la vacuna de sinovac
aparentemente eran vacunas de cortesía
que había enviado china a perú para que
fueran estudiadas
porque el laboratorio chino estaba
investigando para desarrollar esta
vacuna contra el kobe 19 y estas
muestras fueron enviadas a perú para que
fueran evaluadas evaluarán allí su
idoneidad y a través de su inoculación a
voluntarios podrán determinar si esta
vacuna podría ser adquirida o no en perú
para llevar a cabo un
de vacunación aparentemente la selección
de los voluntarios fue totalmente
arbitraria al menos haciendo que dan a
entender los hechos hasta el momento el
escándalo llevó a la renuncia de la
ministra de salud pilar mazzetti y
también de la cancillería peruana
elizabeth astete el ex presidente martín
vizcarra también está acusado de haber
sido inmunizado vizcarra al principio lo
desmintió luego aceptó su culpa mire
asumo mi responsabilidad en ese sentido
y por el respeto que merecen los
ciudadanos de mi país
pido disculpas sinceras a los peruanos y
peruanas por no haber informado de ese
hecho en ese momento me someto a las
investigaciones en aras de esclarecer
esta situación
reafirmando que no he cometido delito
alguno
ni ha existido aquí un perjuicio en
contra de nadie
el vacuna gay te envía un mensaje muy
negativo a los peruanos que ya
desconfían de los gobernantes de la
clase política de los funcionarios
nuevamente parece que la corrupción y la
impunidad hacen de las suyas y
profundiza la incertidumbre entre los
ciudadanos sobre el posible rumbo que
puede tener el país que es uno de los
más golpeados por la pandemia con más de
1.2 millones de casos confirmados y más
de 44 mil personas han fallecido allí en
perú no podemos olvidar tampoco las
escenas de saturación de los hospitales
la falta de oxígeno en algunos centros
asistenciales y los constantes
confinamientos en las diferentes
regiones porque simplemente el
coronavirus no le ha dado tregua perú
sobre el vacuna gates también comentó el
actual presidente francisco sagasti
estamos remitiendo esta lista que hemos
solicitado para conocer la verdad sobre
lo sucedido a la contraloría general de
la república al ministerio público a la
procuraduría general del estado ya la
comisión investigadora que ha formado el
ministro de salud para que de acuerdo a
sus competencias inicien las secciones
que corresponden para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a matilde ureta de clap
punk y psicoanalista de la asociación
internacional y de la sociedad peruana
de psicoanalistas ella está en la ciudad
de piura en el norte de perú y también
está con nosotros
iván montoya docente de derecho penal en
la universidad católica donde también
dirige un grupo de investigación de
derecho penal y de corrupción él se
encuentra en la ciudad de lima que es la
capital peruana les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
de este debate pueden dejar todas las
preguntas y los comentarios en las redes
sociales la recuerdo estamos en facebook
también no se encuentran en instagram y
en twitter como france24
s arroba sant y luego mi cuenta personal
la etiqueta es numeral
el debate efe 24 pues tenemos el tema
tenemos el contexto y quiero comenzar
entonces preguntándole a iván en la
ciudad de lima esta sucesión de
escándalos en perú de crisis políticas
de presidentes y gobiernos interinos
ahora este escándalo con las vacunas
unas esperadas vacunas que estaban
ansiosos los peruanos por recibir que
representa esto para perú a solamente
unas pocas semanas de las elecciones
presidenciales
bueno primero gracias por la invitación
hay varias sensaciones que ha generado
como impacto esta noticia este
develamiento no una que ha mencionado
usted una desconfianza una acentuación
de la desconfianza de nuestra ciudadanía
en la clase política y en sus
gobernantes
digamos indignación profunda por esta
prioridad de los intereses personales
sobre el interés general
yo diría que también se puso en riesgo
la legitimidad de los ensayos de tercera
fase que se estaban haciendo en el perú
eso nos ha dicho mucho pero creo que
internamente se sabe que hay un ha
puesto en cuestión un poco en riesgo esa
esa legitimidad y sobre las elecciones
que son próximas también creo que se
reflejan en las últimas encuestas en el
perú
a pocos dos meses y un poquito menos
para las elecciones en el perú se nota
una una apatía enorme en tener una
decisión ya formada por quién votar o
por quién se inclinaría votar hay una
cantidad importante porcentaje
importante del electorado peruano que no
define o no quiere definir por quién
votar en este momento entonces creo que
el impacto es este es fuerte no ese
sería el lado político de esta situación
de esta crisis desatada por por este
escándalo le pregunto ahora matilde en
la ciudad de piura en el norte del país
por la otra cara de la moneda y es como
acá esta sensación para los peruanos que
ya han visto una sucesión de crisis y de
inestabilidad en su país de hecho están
en este momento en un gobierno de
interinidad bueno me confirman y me
confirman que vamos a restablecer la
conexión entonces con matilde en la
ciudad de piura de más adelante entonces
vamos a hablar con ella retomó la
comunicación con iván en lima para
seguir analizando este este tema e iván
allí en la capital peruana
como queda entonces la figura del ex
presidente martín vizcarra que en el
momento en que fue depuesto del cargo
salió con un 80 por ciento de
favorabilidad por parte de los peruanos
ahora las cosas comienzan a cambiar
si la situación del presidente vizcarra
ha ido deteriorándose progresivamente
los pequeños hubo acopio de popularidad
en algún momento por algunas acciones
que eran correctas estaban teniendo un
buen impacto vinculadas al
fortalecimiento de la institucionalidad
democrática ha ido degenerando
un poco antes de su caída por una serie
de develamiento sobre actos de
corrupción que cuando él fue gobernador
en una región en el perú y que se
acentúa ahora definitivamente con esto
que hemos descubierto y que aún él no
reconoce con plenitud ésta está a pedido
de disculpas es parcial porque él solo
se disculpa de la poca transparencia que
tuvo pero sigue insistiendo en que él
participó en los ensayos pero en
realidad él estuvo por fuera de los
ensayos como estos estás 487 personas
que han estado por fuera del nivel de
los ensayos no han sido parte de ello no
son parte de yo creo que en el caso del
ex presidente es lo que en este momento
está en juego ya el congreso de manera
bastante rápida ha planteado una
acusación constitucional
creo yo que van a plantear su
inhabilitación como una suerte de
proceso un proceso que se sigue dentro
del parlamento y que tiene dos
vertientes una que le levanten el el
aforamiento para que la fiscalía de la
nación continúe con él como cualquier
procesado pero también el propio
congreso establecer una sanción que
puede llegar a la inhabilitación de diez
años para el ejercicio de la función
pública eso es lo que está creo que en
curso respecto del ahora si retomamos la
conexión con matilde allí en el norte
pero matilde le estaba preguntando por
esta noticia esta crisis desatada al
darse a conocer esta inoculación de 487
personas fuera de la investigación que
estaban desarrollando allí la
farmacéutica en conjunto con dos
universidades peruanas como acá esto
para la sociedad peruana para el peruano
de a pie que ve a la clase política cada
vez más inmersa en diferentes escándalos
de corrupción
de esa sociedad espiritual o la
desconfianza ha aumentado yo diría que
estamos en un momento de crisis muy
grave colectivamente hablando
la situación es moderado ahora yo no veo
que ahí hay algo de la teoría del chivo
espiatorio en relación a la vista para
que no creo que él sea el culpable de
todo pero phillips está realmente
pagando como chivo espiatorio lo que un
grupo bastante grande de personas
son responsables no creo que sea el
único y mucho menos pero en general es
situaciones muy críticas y casi sin
temor a equivocarme qué
muy dolorosa muy dormidos
matilde para la clase política peruana
esa confianza se ha comenzado a romper o
se ha roto ya en diferentes escenarios
con estas múltiples crisis políticas y
remezones que ha tenido pero
recientemente se erosiona entonces esa
relación esa confianza entre el
ciudadano normal y la clase política
totalmente totalmente yo creo que casi
va a aparecer con un absurdo tener
elecciones generales dentro de menos de
dos meses ya de por sí ya que los
políticos estaban muy dejados de lado y
con mucha desconfianza a ellos pero esto
ha sido un golpe de gracia para que la
población se siente burlada birlada y
decepcionada abandonada y muy yo creo
que es muy serio lo que está pasando muy
serio muy grave realmente y por supuesto
la desconfianza es total
además tenemos que añadir el factor real
biológico de que tenemos 100 mil muertos
todos todos y cada uno de nosotros los
peruanos tenemos familiares amigos bots
por los muertos y además como no se les
ha podido ni despedir ni velar
milagritos realmente he dicho en dos
palabras pero si es calidad es una gran
tragedia
usted lo califica como una gran tragedia
esta erosión que yo le estoy mencionando
y este de esta desconexión con la clase
política
matilde esto a que daría paso cuando
está este descontento este miedo por la
misma situación que están viviendo los
peruanos por la pandemia del comil 19 la
incertidumbre económica y ver que la
clase política no toma decisiones y
cuando las toma es para su beneficio
psicológicamente esto cómo afecta al
ciudadano
pero totalmente pues si usted fue maquis
imaginar lo desalienta por decirlo
desesperanza y lo ubica en el peor lugar
de la incertidumbre entonces por eso
repito es que es una situación muy unida
desde el punto de vista psicológico y
psiquiátrico es una población muy
amenazada en este momento y por supuesto
en el pse exterior la última noticia que
es necesario incluso un ataque físico a
la casa de vistalba con piedras etcétera
actos de violencia incluso hasta hace
una hora o una hora y media ahora no sé
si ya los han soportado pero está como
decir estamos como al borde del
precipicio
al borde de un precipicio iván en la
ciudad de lima estaba perú al borde de
un precipicio en términos políticos en
términos de esa desconexión que estamos
mencionando con matilde en cuanto a la
clase política del gobierno y a los
ciudadanos por este marco de la pandemia
a ver yo coincido en que si es una
situación trágica es una vez más hay una
situación dolorosa de
como una especie de traición de la clase
política a la ciudadanía es gravísimo lo
que dice coincido en ese sentido pero el
perú
tiene en todos los episodios que ha
podido haber semejantes a esto aunque
creo que este es grave más grave
probablemente pero en muchos episodios
el perú ha podido revertir esa situación
es decir hay como bolsones importantes
de integridad de la propia ciudadanía un
grupo de fiscales que aborda y no le
importa y lleva con todo y descubre y
devela la verdad se establecen sanciones
por supuesto que no es lo saludable que
siempre estemos en un nivel de
resistencia frente al ataque de la
corrupción y de la y de la deshonestidad
de la clase política pero pero digamos
lo que quiero decir es que yo tengo
esperanzas en ese en ese reducto de
integridad de los ciudadanos sobre todo
de los jóvenes de algunos sectores
importantes de la función pública la
fiscalía también en el ejecutivo que
quieren cumplir su función integran
también en el ámbito de los médicos es
impresionante la forma como entregan día
a día su sacrificio y su trabajo
entonces sí reposamos en todo
una renovación de la esperanza en
condiciones adversas el perú por
supuesto no llegará a ese piso a ese a
ese a ese desmoronamiento como
probablemente así algunos lo podemos ver
tengo optimismo en esos reductos de
integridad y de aire y de buen hacer y
de importancia del interés público que
muchos ciudadanos y también mucha clase
política y la función pública pueden en
este momento desempeñar entonces
esperemos un poco las medidas que se
están tomando y esperemos también sé que
no es fácil decirlo que en dos meses se
tenga conciencia de por quién votar y
tengamos aunque sea una clase política
gobernante en julio del 2021
la menos mala posible y que por lo menos
tenga conciencia del interés público
y de la función pública y que deje de
lado ese interés particular y podemos
avanzar poco a poco en reconstruir esa
confianza que se ha resquebrajado en
este momento iván qué tanto se puede
confiar en la justicia peruana
para que las personas que están
implicadas en este caso y en otros casos
previos que hemos reportado en los
últimos meses de corrupción y en otros
casos que han generado también
relaciones políticos alguien pero que
tanto se puede confiar allí en la
justicia para que esto lleve a condenas
ejemplares por lo menos para que le
demuestre a los ciudadanos que están
pagando por lo que han hecho
bueno en este momento ya la fiscalía de
la nación ha abierto una investigación
preliminar contra vizcarra contra la
ministra este té contra la ministra de
salud y contra la que resulte
responsables en este momento a nivel de
los aforados también se está iniciando
investigación a otro nivel con los
funcionarios e intermedios
y yo diría que sí siendo realistas la
clase judicial pero ghanam a fiscales y
jueces por supuesto hay grandes
extensiones todavía de corrupción en
distintas zonas no no todos pero pero sí
también hay jueces y fiscales honestos
esto podemos detectarlo por ejemplo en
esta en ésta hay un grupo de fiscales
llegamos relativamente jóvenes jueces
relativamente jóvenes que están por
ejemplo en los procesos conocidos como
los jueces vinculados a los cuellos
blancos del puerto que tiene que ver con
el develamiento de corrupción en el
sector judicial ahí hay un equipo de
fiscales y un equipo de jueces que está
avanzando las investigaciones hay otro
otro equipo de fiscales que están viendo
los casos de odebrecht y probablemente
con las dificultades que tienen los
procedimientos están haciendo
revelaciones importantes entonces yo
tengo confianza en que si deberíamos en
estos grupos de fiscales relativamente
jóvenes y jueces también que pueden
asumir su rol o están asumiendo su rol
con integridad con el sentido del rol
que le corresponde a la magistratura en
este momento y que llegarán a un buen
puerto a establecer las sanciones que
corresponde sea del personaje que
corresponde y con la mayor objetividad e
imparcialidad posible y con respeto
irrestricto al derecho de defensa son
gente que va a ir hasta las últimas
consecuencias estoy convencido matilde
otra vez conectamos con usted en piedra
en el norte de perú usted que conoce
meticulosamente el comportamiento humano
y la mente humana
este tipo de situaciones en donde se
mezcla el miedo con el descontento y la
rabia que puede desencadenar violencia
apatía en las elecciones que se vienen
en dos meses que lectura puede hacer
usted
yo soy incitó al doctor montoya su
suerte
existe excelente esperanza le diría que
si los ciudadanos y los paisanos míos
logros desde la mitad de la esperanza
que él tiene probablemente estemos
salvados pero yo creo que el mayor deseo
una posibilidad real yo creo que estamos
hablando de un año del cielo y la
cuarentena
muy dura muy difícil de la cual ha sido
el efecto traumático sobre el cual se ha
añadido esta gran decepción por olivia
yo no creo que en dos meses se puedan
revertir tanto las cosas por supuesto
estoy totalmente de acuerdo con el
doctor montoya que es un deseo que
tenemos todos los peruanos de tener una
capacidad de resiliencia que nos permita
salvarnos y salvar no sólo la parte sino
la población y a los conciudadanos estoy
totalmente de acuerdo que ese deseo que
tenemos la gente de bien lo que yo me
temo es que eso sea más un deseo que una
posibilidad real yo veo que es ahí
probablemente por deformación
profesional de ambos hecho o valioso y
sirva de lista yo veo más del aspecto
psiquiátrico digamos de la conducta y
metemos los traumas no son tan distintos
son tan fáciles de arreglar en poco
tiempo
tampoco así que si bien es cierto hemos
pasado cosas terribles con los
anteriores gobernantes que hemos tenido
gravísimas gravísimas también es cierto
que el tejido social se destruyó y hasta
estábamos recién pudiendo salir de un
entramado sumamente patológico y ahora
viene la pandemia y el siglo las siete
plagas de egipto la pandemia y luego lo
de las vacunas es un golpe tras otro o
sea qué bueno que creamos deseemos y
luchemos y sigamos trabajando no sólo
poniendo el hombro poniendo todo lo que
podamos el alma para poder salir
adelante pero veo una situación delicada
matilde a tal vez usted me puede
responder una pregunta que he tenido yo
desde hace mucho tiempo y es porque las
sociedades de américa latina- no
solamente la peruana lo vemos también en
méxico en panamá en chile lo vemos
también en brasil porque ante estos
gobiernos corruptos que constantemente
están todo el tiempo saliendo a la luz
diferentes casos de corrupción las
sociedades no se unen y no hacen nada al
respecto simplemente callan en la
mayoría de los casos y son unos pocos
los que salen a exigir a manifestarse
cuál es ese entendimiento que se puede
hacer de la genética latinoamericana qué
es lo que pasa por nuestra mente no
fingir la crítica yo diría el desde la
humanidad no
el ser humano es un animal y está muy
determinado por la biología no sólo por
la cultura porque usted ha mencionado
algunos países pero nos mencionaba
venezuela que es el más grave de todos
así que para hablar de corrupción
entonces yo no creo que sea un problema
de ser sudamericano yo creo que más bien
obedece a un problema biológico y
genético de la raza de la humanidad en
su conjunto
nosotros vemos que el problema por
ejemplo de las vacunas no ha sido solo
en el peru
hasta en méxico hay tal japonés si se
participa parte del mundo lo cual me
inclina a pensar que es un problema más
de los humanos no de los latinos
mexicanos sino que los seres humanos
funcionamos ante todo con una parte
neurológica que es muy sensible
tiene un centro en el cerebro
y dispara el miedo y el miedo es un muy
mal
acompañante de procesos sociales o
políticos el miedo es capaz de levantar
no sólo por uno sino guerras infinitas
matanzas infinitas entonces
y yo espero que todavía nuestro nivel
civilizatorio al decir del gran
sociólogo norbert elias no es todavía
suficientemente desarrollado como para
armar un consenso político moral
biológico que permita hablar de una
civilización más avanzada en ese sentido
y que creo que nuestra visita funda
diferencias económica y egoísta así que
eso no se ha asignado más si mete magali
iván retomó con ustedes el análisis más
político de este tema y le preguntó por
la posición en la que queda el gobierno
interino del presidente francisco
sagasti veíamos al inicio del programa
las reacciones pidiendo solicitando que
avanzara la investigación para
determinar cómo se armó todo este
entramado cuál es su opinión al respecto
bueno primero saludar el eficiente el
realismo de matilde yo también lo soy
digamos tal vez ella reconoce mi
optimismo que creo que ahí hay algunas
diferencias simplemente desde estados
pero creo que partimos de la misma base
en el caso de el presidente de sagasti
él tiene una posición frágil él no tiene
un partido no hay un partido político
pero el pequeño minoritario digamos pero
en este momento incluso el mismo se
diferencia de ese partido y trata de
decir que es un gobierno de emergencia y
transición no pueden desconocer los
oyentes de tu programa de que se haga
este viene de reemplazar a vizcarra y
tiene y vizcarra ya venía de reemplazar
a otro presidente entonces no son los
directamente digamos elegidos son
elegidos pero debemos no eran los
titulares foto popular
digamos que eran parte de la terna
vizcarra fue parte de la terna del voto
popular pero digamos los que han
sucedido en la asociación que la
constitución autoriza su posición la de
la de sagasti es una posición frágil y
débil repito su grupo político que lo
podría apoyar es pequeño y minoritario
en el congreso segundo
hay una hay un grupo en el congreso que
tiene una entiendo muy bien hasta ahora
que es lo que lo determina actuar de tal
manera que socava o intenta socavar la
estabilidad democrática del país
por ejemplo en este momento sin ninguna
razón porque el presidente sagasti su
primera ministra
ninguno de ellos está involucrado salvo
una ministra que inmediatamente se actuó
haciéndola cesar en el cargo y sus
viceministros igualmente de manera
inmediata has estado en el cargo decir
el presidente y la primera ministra no
conocían de esos de esos episodios
entonces están actuando por lo menos con
la corrección que se exige en este
momento no hay razones para removerlo en
este momento y ya se escuchan algunos
ruidos de removerlo en el cargo por lo
tanto pues eso sería verdaderamente
criminal por parte de este sector del
congreso que intente desestabilizar por
lo tanto creo que evidentemente se haga
sistema una posición débil pero sólo
espero que como siempre ocurrido en el
perú que la opinión pública decente
que tiene intuye que es la presidencia
intenta sacar adelante el país en esta
crisis se opongan rotundamente a estos a
estos conatos de intento de
desestabilización y permitamos llegar al
28 de julio con las elecciones y aunque
las condiciones que corresponda pero
llegar a las elecciones y con un proceso
de vacunación acentuado en marcha e
ininterrumpido no creo que yo espero y
tengo confianza de que error de sagasti
permanezca digamos este y que le dé
cierta estabilidad democrática en este
contexto de crisis y van puntualmente
cómo afectará esto entonces las
elecciones presidenciales que ustedes
tienen en los próximos meses estaremos
ante un escenario de alta abstención
bueno hay dos motivos la apatía que
corresponde a
al contexto que acaba de descubrirse hay
una suerte que se refuerza es apatía en
la clase y desconfianza en la clase
política y la no deseo de participar en
las elecciones y otra el tema del miedo
efectivamente a la pandemia entonces
esto sí va en eso coincido con matilde
algunos riesgos de poca participación de
que se desdibuje la legitimidad
democrática de estas elecciones pero soy
un convencido de que tiene que
producirse deben de hacerse los
esfuerzos necesarios para garantizar la
participación de la mayor cantidad con
la mejor información repito es difícil
pero hay que llegar al 28 de julio con
elecciones este producidas
tal vez matilde ahí no coincida conmigo
pero pero creo que es saludable que
lleguemos al proceso democrático salvo
que se acentúen la catástrofe nacional
vinculada a la pandemia a los muertos
infección
matilde su opinión al respecto y ya pasó
a continuación a preguntarles por las
conclusiones
si no coincide totalmente por el doctor
montoya yo creo que es deseable desde el
punto de vista político y social de las
elecciones porque es un hito que va a
permitir organizar a la población
arañó digamos así la transferencia la
continuidad la del 3 de nando y tener un
polo de dos las elecciones
institucionalmente hablando nos van a
dar un referente que va a ser muy
importante estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con eso lo que sí creo es que a estas
alturas y todos hemos escuchado y
escuchamos todos los días a la gente
decir que no hay ningún candidato que
valga la pena exite ahora no quiero
estudiar mucho pero yo sí creo pero a
ver bastante ausencia de votaciones de
votantes
creo que si hay que llevar adelante las
fechas los estados ya para las
elecciones porque insisto y repito creo
que es un referente que organiza si se
quiere la novia que estamos viviendo y
creo que es por eso muy importante pero
[Música]
digamos que es una etapa muy difícil y
muy dura
tenía otra pregunta y paso ya estoy
llegando al final del programa matilde
aprovecho que estoy en conexión con
usted para que me dé sus conclusiones
qué va a pasar en perú después de estas
elecciones después de este remezón que
cree usted que va a ser el escenario que
se va a enfrentar el país después de la
mitad de año muy puntual por favor para
que levantarme puedo hacer su conclusión
y finalizar mire este deseo por supuesto
es que sea de orden seguridad y de una
democracia ni inmanente o máximamente
respetada cual creo que que es lo que
creo que danza no tengo la bola de
cristal y de vidrio para poder este
decir que es lo que va a ocurrir estamos
ahora en un tiempo
decisiones y de formulación es casi
cotidianas para todos así que se hace
muy muy difícil hablar lo que pueda
pasar de aquí a seis 6 meses y mucho más
difícil para hablar de aquí a un año
yo luego a todos los santos y a todos
los dioses del mundo que nos ayude y que
podamos tener una resiliencia alguna
respuesta colectiva suficientemente
saludable lo ruego lo deseo y por eso
trabajo y ha sido a eso pero siento que
la situación y el futuro
difícil muy delicado
iván su conclusión qué va a pasar en
perú después de estas elecciones
teniendo como antecedentes estos
remezones políticos
bueno yo espero primero que las
investigaciones que se han iniciado
respecto a lo que ha ocurrido determinen
sanciones inmediatas y procesos en
marcha paralelo a ello espero que el
gobierno ofrezca las mayores garantías
para un proceso democrático con
participación que se dé en los canales
donde los partidos políticos expresen
sus propuestas con claridad y la gente
pueda distinguir aunque sea difícil en
este contexto pueda distinguir las
propuestas más razonables viables y
digamos pensadas en el perú y distinguir
de otras que no son responsables y tener
con las garantías por supuesto de las
seguridades que pueda suponer el riesgo
de participar en conglomerados en el
acto de votación por supuesto y también
se tiene que brindar todas las
seguridades y al final quiero tener la
esperanza de que el pueblo peruano va a
poder escoger a un gobierno repito con
digamos el menos mal lo simple decimos
en el perú pero que tenga por lo menos
alguna visión de mediano y largo plazo
que ordene la casa como dice matilde que
se preocupe en el interés público y
reorganice el sistema sanitario peruano
el sistema educativo y con ello por lo
menos sienta las bases el próximo
gobierno sienta las bases esenciales
respecto de políticas de salud
cinemáticas educativas que permitan
luego al perú salir de este escollo en
el que se encuentra
actualmente pues a matilde ureta de clap
ans que en la ciudad de piura en el
norte de perú ya iván montoya en lima la
capital peruana les agradezco por haber
compartido con nosotros sus puntos de
vista
el vacuna gate apenas está comenzando
hay una investigación en curso que
seguramente estaremos aquí analizando
tan pronto tengamos alguna respuesta por
parte de las autoridades pero a ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con la programación de france 24
[Música]